could Paramount actually lose Terry
metalis the savior of Star Trek to
Disney I'm my no
God no God please no no
no no what does that mean for legacy
welcome to sidet Trek your Sci-Fi TV and
movie
channel
[Music]
well Terry metalis is actually already
working for Disney he is doing a TV
series of the Race to Witch Mountain I
don't know why they're redoing that the
rocketed version of it a while ago and
it was brilliant so just leave it at
that for me but teralis is writing and
actually producing that series and it's
not a million miles away from actually
appearing on our screens so Disney
already have their claws into the savior
of Star Trek but there are rumors that
they want to go even further don't
forget about c.co do.uk that's our
dedicated website where we do articles
based on most of our stories and we try
to throw in a little bit more
information for you to digest please go
and check it out and don't forget we're
also on patreon where you get to see
most of our videos a day before
everybody else and for a small
contribution that really supports
Channel you get to watch them without
the adverts as well can't say fair than
that and actually they've been very
impressed by Terry metalis and they
would quite like to keep him even
apparently there's conversations about a
Marvel series being maybe pointed in his
Direction and that would be very
difficult for him to say no to now
Paramount could get Talis to do Star
Trek Legacy in a heartbeat we have seen
him in several interviews talking about
how much he desperately wanted to be
involved in Star Trek he's worked on
several Star Trek Seasons before and
obviously he brought us Picard season 3
which I think most trekkies would agree
has been the best or at least our
favorite incarnation of curtzman Trek so
Paramount you'd think will be trying to
get him signed on to something to keep
hold of him but they haven't and it does
look like that Disney might have taken
advantage of that because at the end of
the day it doesn't matter how much toy
metalis wants to do Star Trek he also
probably likes eating and paying for
like rent and stuff so if Disney are
going to give him a job and give him
something interesting to work on I'm
absolutely certain he'll bite their hand
offer it and at the end of the day he
can't wait for Paramount CBS Studios
forever to actually green like Star Trek
Legacy now I've actually spoken about
this a couple of times before though and
I have been told by somebody that
actually is pretty close to power Mount
that yes they are going to do Star Trek
Legacy I've actually heard one rumor
that is suggesting that strange new
worlds will end after season 3 or could
even end now and that they would
actually just do a straight to TV movie
now that I don't think is a very likely
scenario but there are Executives at
Paramount that think that's the way to
go they want to have one maybe two
timelines within Star Trek they don't
want the current three they think it's
confusing and they would much rather
have a little bit of a reset and get
back to something that fans can
understand or recognize as Star Trek
rather than just kurtzman Trek So the
plan end strange new worlds crack on
with Star Trek Legacy and potentially
not move forwards with Star Trek Academy
now there are lots of Star Trek fans
will think that's a brilliant idea
Unfortunately they may not have the
votes over at CBS and Paramount there is
a relatively small minority apparently
of those top people at the studios that
think this is the best way to go other
people think they actually should trust
kurtzman and just let him go his own way
if kurtzman does get his own way we
might not get Legacy we will get Academy
which is Star Trek 90210 as far as I'm
concerned and we'll end up getting quite
a lot more strange new worlds
so Paramount also are not in any rush to
actually Green Light Star Trek Legacy
while the other two seasons are running
just because it's really expensive and
they do need to cut back a lot of costs
something I've not really spoken about
before is that Paramount are in massive
massive debt um over 156 billion dolls
but that's not really the major problem
the major problem is a lot of those
debts have to be renegotiated in the
next 12 months and interest rates have
gone up so when when those debts are
actually renegotiated they're going to
be more expensive par mount's already
been overspending massively on Paramount
plus and the TV shows that are going
there so they have to cut spending so
they've slowed down the calendar for
Star Trek they've stretched a lot of
stuff out that's not just because of the
strikes but also because of this money
issue and that means that really strange
new worlds needs to end before we get
Legacy now ter Talis the savior of Star
Trek would have been perfect to take on
that mantle he obviously has thought
about Legacy a lot he's talked about it
a lot he set it up in
peard so what if he is poached by Disney
does parmount have a plan on how to move
forward with the show anyway well yes
Jonathan fraks so according to somebody
that I've been speaking to Jonathan
Frakes was very very much front and
center where it came to Picard season 3
he directed several of the episodes
Reiko was a massively important part of
the series and he's done lots of
interviews Etc since he has been very
very public he's obviously directed
several disco episodes and strange new
worlds episodes he really is becoming
Star Trek's director Paramount
apparently had been very happy with his
work and very happy more importantly
with his public persona he is a Star
Trek man he could actually fix a lot of
the perceptions of Star Trek in the Trek
family because there is division within
house trekkies some of us love kurtzman
Trek some of us not so much and some of
us absolutely hate it one way Paramount
could maybe fix some of those problems
is by bringing in somebody like Jonathan
Franks to steer the ship now apparently
he wouldn't be brought in as as sort of
like a showrunner but he would maybe
have a far more prominent and far more
important role in actually developing
Star Trek Legacy and really being the
frontman for the show he would obviously
probably continue directing he might
even appear in the odd episode but he
would really take on a lot of talis's
role in the development Etc and would
really be as I said the frontman for the
show if Talis is stolen by Disney and
they do get him on a long-term project
maybe something with Marvel maybe it's
just escaped to Witch Mountain that
really will be a big loss to Star Trek
because he really was the fundamental
driving force behind what made peard
season 3 so brilliant and I really
really hope Paramount realized that
before they lose the
opportunity guys though get into the
comments and tell me what you think is
Town Metalist really vital for Paramount
moving forwards with star trekk but also
which side of this division within the
Paramount Executives do you land on are
you with the minority that want Less
trekk in away and only two timelines at
most some Executives apparently are
arguing just one and do you actually
agree with them that we don't need Star
Trek Academy we just need a prime Star
Trek we just need Star Trek Legacy or do
you agree with the other side and
actually do you love what star trekk has
done so far do you love how creative
it's been and let's be honest it has
been really creative even if I
personally haven't always loved what
they've done like the musical I can at
least appreciate what they're trying to
do so kurtman he doesn't quite have my
vote but I can at least respect what
he's trying which side of that argument
do you fall on get into the comments and
tell me if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to
patreon.com where most of our new videos
Premiere first and you get to see them
without the adverts and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel and you even get a
free gift after three months you get to
see them
first as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next
[Music]
time